well what was your camping experience
like in england in england i didn't
really go much in england i went around
like france mainly
a lot of the time in france though like
it was like campsites like that did you
camp with
my family for the most part but then uh
obviously because we're in wales so it's
really easy
to just camp for a weekend um and it was
normally you were just like in a in a
farmer's land
in like some [ __ ] random field oh
like land that someone owns yeah oh you
because you could just
because they they'd always know someone
you could just be like oh can we camp
and it maybe it'd be like a 10 or a
night
okay because they didn't really want
anything they were just like don't just
leave a mess just clean everything out
because you can't do that in australia
it needs to be in like like a national
reserve
no you can actually you can do whatever
you want on the land so
normally you're right next to woods and
stuff so yeah obviously there's no power
outlets or anything and yeah
probably a decent walk away from the car
that you came in yeah yeah yeah
yeah so yeah it was just good fun though
i mean you just normally just set up the
tent
if you can get a fire going go ahead but
it might be raining a [ __ ] time and you
might have to start drinking beers in
the tent like
if you squished in this tent like how
you guys doing all right nice someone
want to ball the kettle
uh get some pot noodles going you know
uh whatever whatever you do we did like
uh
uh duke of edinburgh as well we did that
oh yeah that was good fun as well yeah
because in japan
you can't even like put a fire on the
ground
you need this like fire like a fire pit
well because sometimes in some places
you'd clean up after yourself and it was
easier to just bring something that you
could wrap the
like all the ash in yeah yeah which is
like i think we did that a few times
because it's just because if you have to
clean it up sometimes it's an absolute
pain in the ass getting rid of all this
ash well because in australia all you
did was just dig a hole
and then once once you were done with
the ash you just fill up that hole again
i mean it's good for the land but i mean
sometimes you can't do that in some
places
yeah i mean it's whatever i just kind of
like it was never more than like two
nights it was always like a night
yeah put the tent up kind of get drunk
yeah eat a lot of bacon in the morning
and baking sandwiches yeah yeah
two nights i feel is like the optimal
camping time yeah i'd say sorry
two nights is about right it depends if
you because you need something to do the
second day
yeah cause cause the first night you
you're setting up you're having a few
drinks
what do you do during the whole second
day before you start drinking you can't
you can't immediately get like
start drinking beers at like 11. i mean
that's what we did that's kind of what
we did i mean
i guess but then there's someone like
driving right no i don't know i mean i i
kind of want to do something i don't
know
yeah well that's when you can bring the
tv and connect it to the power hour yeah
well because it's something if you're
like who's got the switch with british
people
you know and there's like four of you
like a 24 pack sorry smash so much that
a 24 pack won't last like more than a
night that's true
so how much beer are you bringing along
for this thing right you can't do day
drinking that's like you need like 40
beers at least for that whole experience
but i mean that's why i like doing
something mm-hmm uh that's why i got
away
i mean we had we brought like a pack of
cards and like you know that kind of
stuff i mean we never cracked them up
we just left them there for like
decorations yeah i was just having too
much [ __ ] fun with the fire
enthusiastic fire burning like 24
7. yeah well you're like like a good 24
hours jesus christ just because we
[ __ ] adventured out and got all the
wood right that's
that's half that was half the fun like
what did you do the second day when you
say you
you slept in the tent the first night no
no no no no no no we didn't we didn't
sleep in the first night because we we
got there
like super super early on the second day
um because we
the first day it was raining like crazy
the first day we missed the day of
camping so we did what anyone do and
just
had a nice day at an onsen yeah and
slept at with a nice roof over our heads
um and then we just went there the
second day and we just basically stayed
there all day yeah we got there like
9 00 a.m or something yeah like super
early in the morning so it was like a
full full day
because i was in look at the area near
you and the storm was [ __ ] brutal
oh yeah i mean the storm in tokyo was
brutal as well